[Applause]
hi
everybody it's monday
i'm i'm pretty enthusiastic about
mondays and we are
kicking off this week with pet
adoption week
i'm so excited i really am this was like
an
early dream and i work with this
incredible producer marianne and every
day i'd be like are we doing the pet
adoption yet is it happening
she's like it's in processes and process
there's a lot that goes into it but
we're actually doing it and it's a dream
realized and
douglas come here this is actually my
rescue
douglas
he is 12 years old and he has a heart of
gold
i took him like when i first got him to
alaska for three months and here's the
amazing thing about douglas is
he'll just stay in bed with you for like
18 hours
like he has an incredible bladder like
he's like a camel
and he just like will nuzzle forever
he's amazing so
when you see all these pets this week i
don't think you're gonna be able to say
no
and maybe you can like find a friend
and they can find their forever home and
we're gonna it's gonna be amazing i'm so
excited
douglas is representing okay
yay so um i hope that you guys all had a
relaxing weekend i spent mine doing one
of my favorite things spending time with
my daughters and
we went pumpkin picking we went to the
patch yeah
so something happened and i don't know
why
but it was like love at first sight i
felt
this urge to hug this pumpkin and
i think i might be dating him i
i had like this giving tree moment like
it turned into a shell silverstein story
and needless to say i took a lot of
pictures of our first date
and then my daughters found their
pumpkin which is so big
it we need a crane actually to bring it
in and the truth is
they're all in the back of my minivan
and they're coming here and we're going
to decorate the studio with all the
pumpkins that we gathered this weekend
and it tis the season like i'm from
california we don't do things like that
um so anyway it didn't end well for the
giving tree and it probably won't end
well for this pumpkin because i'm going
to carve him and eat a seed so
anyway vfx have you ever had a pumpkin
related uh
question nikki from georgia
hey i do have a pumpkin related question
i love you and i love carving pumpkins i
love you too
i never remember what to do with the
seeds so do you have a good seed recipe
i actually do i'm not kidding i don't
know if they asked you to ask that
question because it's like too perfect
i'm serious wait i do i even have a
picture of my pumpkin seeds yes
i made these yes
i'm i'm so excited my secret is lowry
seasoning salt
and butter and pan roasting and i'm
actually going to show the recipe
hopefully this week
and how to make it but we've thank you
i'm so excited thank you for letting me
pimp my pumpkin seed recipe
you